there's an old saying you can't escape
Destiny imagine hearing that for the
first time you can't escape
Destiny you don't know what your destiny
is so you do a Google search and find
out that Destiny is a blue-haired gaming
streamer can't escape
Destiny pretty creepy but who are we to
question the Timeless wisdom of an old
saying Destiny is one of the pioneers of
online video game streaming I never got
into the streaming the games part but I
am a gamer I could give Destiny a run
for his money and Pac-Man Miss Pac-Man
Donkey Kong Pole Position asteroids
Frogger cubert Jungle King Defender
paper boy digdug centipede Space
Invaders Galaga Contra Double Dragon
Rampage punchout the
goes on and on and on challenge me and
see what happens I guarant Dizzle T you
will get
embarrassed in the meantime Destiny is
apparently so good at whatever games he
plays that people are interested in his
views on all kinds of other topics
people want to know what Destiny thinks
so when he was on the fresh and fit Show
recently one of the guys either fresh or
fit dumb or Dumber asked destiny who's
an atheist which religion he would pick
if he had to pick one real quick Desy if
you're going to choose a religion to go
to let's just say you're going to choose
religion to go towards which would it be
Islam Christianity Buddhism Destiny was
there debating that swastika shaped pile
of mashed potatoes suan Ahmed who spent
the entire debate blaming Jews for
everything he hates about his miserable
life so Destiny began his answer by
making fun of suan
well I feel like Jews run the world and
are secretly in charge of everything I
feel like I want to be with those dudes
perfect answer to a delusional
conspiracy nut like suan if Jews make up
2% of the world's population and yet
they control absolutely everyone else on
the planet who wouldn't want to be on
that
team but in reality Destiny doesn't
share suliman's fantasies about being
constantly dominated and manhandled by
Jews so he was joking and he went on to
give a more serious response I feel like
from all the things that I've learned
about religion I like Christianity
because I feel like the coolest like
cheerleader guy is Jesus because he's
super selfless he's obviously strong
he's God he does all but he like handles
U you know he treats everybody with
respect even Sinners you know don't
judge the sinner uh Jos s like I feel
like Jesus is like the prime example of
if every single person on the planet
could be a particular figure he would be
the one that you would want to be like
now that's fascinating again Destiny is
an atheist but he says that if he had
had to pick a religion he'd pick
Christianity because of
Jesus I was not expecting that answer AP
the apostate Prophet who's also an
atheist started playing this clip during
one of our live streams and he paused
right before Destiny gave his answer and
he asked me to predict what Destiny
would say which religion would Destiny
pick I thought Destiny would say
something totally different
real quick Desy if you're G to choose a
religion to go to let's just say you're
going to choose a religion to go towards
which would it be Islam what do you
think David what do you think you will
say Destin is being asked if you had to
choose one religion to go to which one
would it
be yes I think Buddhism or some crap so
I thought he was going to say Buddhism
people who are watching made all kinds
of predictions okay what do uh what does
any everyone else think he will say if
he had to pick one
religion and Atheism would be excluded
because it's not a religion what would
he what would Destiny say I'm curious
what he will
say uh little sausage said choose the
cow uh BDSM LW Christianity Christianity
Wicken what
Wicken Islam for
sure uh the
Jews choose Muslims live in Israel I
choose the C Christianity Buddhism since
he is an atheist LOL Buddhism jism
Buddhism Minecraft paaran ISM
Scientology I would say m Minecraft
seems like likely but let's let's see
what he says agnostic that's not a
religion though spaghetti monster
religion this could also be one of the
religions he might pick agnosticism
magic jism he's not going to say
Christianity turism atheism and so on
LOL Wicked Dark Tower ISM okay let's see
what he says imagine our surprise eyes
when Destiny said he would choose
Christianity I feel like from all the
things that I've learned about religion
I like Christianity because I feel like
the coolest like cheerleader guy is
Jesus because he's super selfless he's
obviously strong he's God he does all
the but he like handles uh you know he
treats everybody with respect even
Sinners you know don't judge the sinner
judge the sin like I feel like Jesus is
like the prime example of if every
single person on the planet could be a
particular figure he would be the one
that you would want to be like
so oh that's that's going to be a video
on my channel tomorrow son wow that's it
David that's content for you right there
that we're on your Channel right now and
I can't hit the I can't hit the
Allelujah button now if Destiny had said
he would choose Islam the daag guys
would be using this clip as the new
proof of Islam Destiny says he would
choose Islam you see this is the proof
this is the greatest thing to happen to
Islam since Andrew Tate and
sneo but fortunately we're not the dawa
guys people say all kinds of things
people convert in and out of things all
the time people have all kinds of
preferences Destiny saying he would
choose Christianity proves nothing about
Christianity so why am I talking about
this well I found two things especially
interesting about Destiny's response
first he says almost the same thing that
we find in certain Bible passages he
gave three quick reasons he would choose
Christian Christianity I feel like from
all the things that I've learned about
religion I like Christianity because I
feel like the coolest like cheerleader
guy is Jesus because he's super selfless
he's obviously strong he's God he does
all so Jesus is powerful he's God he's
strong he performs lots of Miracles but
he like handles U you know he treats
everybody with respect even Sinners you
know don't judge the sinner uh judge the
sin like he treated people well even
Sinners it's not quite correct to say
that he treated everyone with respect
Jesus was pretty brutal in his
condemnation of hypocritical religious
leaders but we understand Destiny's
Point people who were regarded as
Sinners and social outcasts loved being
around Jesus I feel like Jesus is like
the prime example of if every single
person on the planet could be a
particular figure he would be the one
that you would want to be like the world
would be a better place if people tried
to be more like
Jesus definitely can't can't say that
about Muhammad so that's why Destiny
would choose Christianity now look at
what the Apostle Paul says in
Philippians 2 in your relationships with
one another have the same mindset as
Christ Jesus who being in very nature
God did not consider equality with God
something to be used to his own
Advantage rather he made himself Nothing
by taking the very nature of a servant
being made in human likeness and being
found in appearance as a man he humbled
himself by becoming obedient to death
even death on a cross therefore God
exalted him to the highest place and
gave him the name that is above every
name that at the name of Jesus every
knee should bow in heaven and on Earth
and under the Earth and every tongue
acknowledge that Jesus Christ is Lord to
the glory of God the Father Paul says
that Jesus was in very nature God but he
humbled himself by taking the nature of
a servant and even as a servant he
continued to Humble himself Paul tells
Christians to have that mindset in their
relationships with other
people quite similar to what Destiny
said I feel like from all the things
that I've learned about religion I like
Christianity because I feel like the
coolest like cheerleader guy is Jesus
because he's super selfless he's
obviously strong he's God he does all
but he like handles uh you know he
treats everybody with respect even
Sinners you know don't judge the sinner
judge the sin like I feel like Jesus is
like the prime example of if every
single person in the planet could be a
particular figure he would be the one
that you would want to be like second
the reason I thought Destiny would say
Buddhism is that the new atheists have
done a pretty amazing job manipulating
people into having an extremely negative
view of Jesus and Christianity if you go
back to the 1980s and 1990s almost every
one in the west including atheists would
have said that if they had to choose a
religion they would choose
Christianity it was easy to look around
and say I like living in a place where
Jesus had a big influence so if I have
to go with someone I'll go with
Jesus the only exceptions would have
been people who prefer something exotic
they'd go with Buddhism just about
everyone else would pick
Christianity but in the early 2000s the
new atheists programmed a generation to
believe that if we don't stop
Christianity right now Christians are
going to establish a Christian theocracy
and execute non-christians and Destroy
science anything you don't like about
the world blame Jesus it's his fault of
course we've seen some serer takes even
from the leaders of the movement I sort
of feel at home in the Christian ethos I
feel that we are a Christian country in
that sense so I I count myself a
cultural Christian I find that I like to
live in a culturally Christian country
but the takeaway at the popular level
was that the world is a worse place
because of Jesus and Christianity
Christianity has been an obstacle to
progress so if you're an atheist now and
you had to pick a religion for some
reason what would it be certainly not
Christianity it's bad not Islam it's
another abrahamic religion not Hinduism
seems too
weird what are you going with Buddhism
right
obviously but Destiny said Christianity
and he gave some surprisingly common
sensical reasons that people 30 or 40
years ago would have taken for
granted this means either that Destiny
just isn't as easy to manipulate as many
other people of his generation or that
he's yet another individual who's
warming up to Christianity because the
promises of the new atheists haven't
come true the new atheists assured us
that if we just get Christianity out of
the way the world will become more
rational more logical more
scientific and yet the moment I mean the
moment large numbers of Christians
started becoming atheists
the entire world suddenly started going
completely
insane so Destiny could just be a hard
target for manipulators or he could be
warming up to Christianity because the
predictions of the new atheists didn't
come true or perhaps both but whatever
the case may be the fact
remains you can't escape
Destiny or
reality or Jesus
[Music]